let's talk about how uh
our unfortunate democrat leadership is
impacting us domestically you know
thanks joe biden for your press
conference talking about how you're
doing really really well meanwhile in
this story from yahoo finance la freight
train looting out of control as thieves
worsen supply chain bottlenecks have you
guys seen these photographs out of l.a
or these videos dude the train stops to
unload and like 50 guys jump on with
bolt cutters snap it open start throwing
tvs out people are just loading up
there's boxes everywhere i was i saw one
report where they were like are you
wondering where your amazon delivery
went perhaps it was lost in an la
freight yard and i'm just like watching
a video there's people filming them do
it this is what's happening on the
ground in this country and you see this
stuff i gotta tell you with the trucker
shortage with a labor shortage with the
airlines freaking out canceling flights
every single month for some new problem
you know ukraine war with russia might
be the least of our worries when you
don't have truckers to bring you food
when your goods being shipped by train
are being looted and and your supplies
being destroyed
well we're going to go local i i got to
say but just really i just want to make
a point china has bullet trains we have
this
[Laughter]
this is true if you guys have i take the
amtrak up to new york every week uh
forget her and i i get on that i'm like
man this is it's basically like the the
joe biden of trains getting on amtrak
but one of the things if if you go to
the press conference just going back to
uh uh brandon for a moment here it was
so bad when he's trying to explain
inflation he was trying to say the
reason for inflation is because of the
supply chain crisis so he's blaming one
crisis that essentially he's allowing to
happen based on another crisis that he's
allowing to happen and it's just the
swirl but this i tell you this story
they were showing some images of the
essentially the yards where it's just
all the empty packages where they've
gone through and ripped everything
there's like you know this entire field
uh look at these photos yeah look at
this pull this stuff up wow this is
absolutely insane i can't believe
it's just looks like l.a the train's
gonna derail by hitting cardboard yeah
that's concerning either need armed
guards at this point whether they're
human or robot or turrets or whatever or
bullet trains like you're saying super
fast trains that are enclosed
inside ian calling for auto defense
guys this is how skynet started as you
laugh and the next thing you know we get
drunk yeah i mean they used to have
armed like a guy would sit on the stage
coach with a shotgun making sure no they
didn't get jumped as they were riding in
the 1800s but now we've become so
complacent that we were like hey i can
walk around without looking both ways
the world's really not that safe have
you ever read or seen judge dredd
yeah yeah i don't know if i want to live
in that world where it's like the trains
are late like you know there's just
layers of auto defense turrets with gun
sights pointing at you as you walk past
me either so let's build
mag rail uh trains
yeah maglev trains that are enclosed
that will also serve a problem yeah
without turrets turretless or we just
have elon musk to build a bunch of his
tunnels yes yeah but it's basically a
traffic jam it's a synergistic uh
company model because not only do you
build the tunnels underground then you
can build the high-speed rail in the
tunnels and then we do it on mars for
instance where he's colonizing i think
we're going local you know one thing
that we've we've been focusing on is
we've got our own garden we've got
chickens we love our chickens they're
silly little things they lay eggs all
the time and so uh we had a homesteader
on the show a while back talking about
how
you know if you even get one or two
percent of of your food source from your
own production you're doing really
really well
and when you look at this stuff it's not
an issue of prepping it's an issue of
let me just say if if you are someone
who has watched joe biden speak
you probably have already started
prepping if you're someone who isn't and
you're only watching cnn i need not warn
you about why you should have some
emergency food or you should learn to
farm or or garden or get some animals
you need only watch joe biden speak if
you watch that man speak just like
literally don't watch a clip watch like
a full thing of him talking and you
still think he is doing a good job and
we're going to be fine then by all means
you do as you please but i think the
average person who has not listened to
the man who doesn't know that he said
once true and on the shabbat of pressure
once they see that they're going to be
like how many beans can i buy in one
trip to walmart because that man is
terrifying me not only that if you watch
joe biden tonight you don't already own
a firearm
i bet tomorrow's going to be about
loudon guns it's going to be you know
record lines out the door be like back
during covet i wonder if we can track
that actually because i i don't dis i
agree yeah i think i think people are
going to go buy guns right if this were
like a militant despotism and we had a
leader like that i was going to ask like
what would happen to them because right
now we kind of have a decentralized
system the united states is pretty
self-sufficient you know we don't really
need a president to get the job done of
course the military needs a leader but
in a country where that's like autocrat
like libya with gaddafi if someone like
that got into power that was like
not there what would happen they just
they just haven't completely murdered
instantly and the new president would
take over and but we we live in a place
where it's not so drastic that that guy
as the president doesn't have to be like
a power monster it can be kind of almost
not there it's good when we have
civilian leadership of our armed forces
and the idea is we have our generals but
then we elect a civilian leader who can
then check them and bring some
accountability the problem is when you
have an old man in a wheelchair with a
blanket on his lap pushed into a sun
room and he falls asleep and goes
there's no one keeping any of these
forces in check or organizing them or
even having a plan for what we're doing
because when you guys are you guys are
like 25th amendment and kamala harris
lol i'm also like no no obvio so what
would happen a go a general would take
control another country
let me ask you something
honest question what would you what
would you prefer
all of this in la or kamala harris
locking all of these people up you know
and many innocent people along with it
right this is the challenge
some people might say you know kamala
harris is a brutal dictator type person
who kept people in prison to use a slave
labor to fight wildfires actually they
actually for a dollar an hour because
these people were my understanding is
that they were eligible for parole and
she was like no we need the cheap labor
to fight wildfires which is basically in
my opinion slavery and you could have
that and it will mean your train tracks
are clean but i do not like the idea of
empowering someone as evil as that woman
and so it's like then what do we get
sleepy joe asleep on the job and
everything starts falling apart it's
like switching a rock and a hard place
so one thing going back to the bernie
reference luke brought up earlier which
during the campaign i'd always kind of
make that joke and i put out a meme a
few times i hear like nancy and kamala
propping them up and you know here's a
antifa flag in the background and white
house burning and all that
i assumed when biden came in to be
weakened at bernie's but it would be
essentially the hardcore libs that were
propping them up here's the thing i
don't think anybody's holding him up i
don't even think ronclain or jennifer
sake or susan spine susan who's hiding
out there in kellyanne's old office i
don't think any to me i would rather go
against the hardcore lefty who at least
we knew look we hate their policies but
we know what direction they're going we
know how to how to fight them we can
challenge them on certain points not
saying that i want to cede any of these
things to these people i'd rather have
someone who's a lefty where at least we
can go and combat them as opposed to
someone who's quite frankly incompetent
i would rather have no government so we
could actually live our lives free and
prosperously in a way where we don't
have centralization and control of our
basic human activities that are
absolutely destroyed by these plutocrats
and and and fat cats but again but but
you know i'll push back a little bit
there's got to be some cooperation
there's got to be some governance it
doesn't i don't mean yeah and i would
argue our cop was going to tell you
can't do things i just mean
the more you increase freedom you also
increase risks of course
and i'm actually cool with a substantial
amount of risk but i think people should
consider that it would be more like the
wild west yeah not all bad you know more
freedom no one's going to bug you when
you want to be on your property minding
your own business but you might get
bugged by some bad people who will you
know be more like we're more more likely
to be unchecked yeah i would argue i
would argue that there would be less
harm uh when it when people get to
figure it out themselves but that's just
my perspective but uh just going on on
topic here again i would be sweating
bullets if i was living in a major city
uh the situation financially is getting
worse it's only going to get worse this
is a slow and deliberate destruction of
this country and what we're seeing on
the railroads is just one symptom of it
this symptom is just a byproduct of this
system crashing financially it's only
going to get worse here the larger
financial ramifications of the lockdowns
the restrictions the mandates we're
still going to feel them and they
haven't been fully even transitioned
into our current state that we're in
right now financial markets take a while
to actually react to certain moves by
governments and i think
it's fair to say especially with how
much we have been indebted with how much
we've been printing that financially the
situation will only get worse here in
the united states and we're going to
have more situations like we're seeing
at the railroads unfold in many
different ways all throughout this
country i always want to point out that
those images i showed i went on google
and i typed in la trains and that was it
wow when you google search la and trains
this is what you see
no
subways you know no no no um sub
stations no smiling people waving with
their kids boarding a train and seeing
their their you know there's there's no
uh husband seeing his wife off as he
boards no it's this all of the images
except for oh here's a pretty one look
at that beautiful the coaster the
coaster on the uh uh the the amtrak and
then everything around it is just decay
and ruin i took that trip once it was
it's very nice oh yeah that's right
you go from la to san diego oh okay the
scary thing is that my prediction is
that gavin newsom is the dumb nominee in
2024. yeah and that is so folks or
whitmore
whitmer yeah well there was there was an
article once that uh and it's not just
one article but they say that california
is what the united states will be five
years later so that what happens in
california affects the rest of the
country five years on
i hope not
i think with the uh the pushback we're
seeing thanks to the internet that's
gonna play a big role in people waking
up and paying attention we're seeing um
hey getter for instance an opportunity
for people to bypass the censorship and
maintain these values and ideas and
share them
if we didn't have that and people were
only able to see this mainstream
narrative then yeah the us would become
california and we would all live in
squalor and destruction so long as we
keep resisting and fighting for free
speech and our ability to share ideas
we're gonna hold that off thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
monday through friday at 8 pm don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you